father we just come before you and give
you thanks for the privilege we have to
sit around these tables and deliberate
on
important future uh issues in our
community and we just ask for wisdom
and clarity as we make our decisions
today we ask that in jesus name amen
thank you
good afternoon councillors and welcome
along to 2022
as far as council meetings go we have uh
one apology today and that is uh
councillor doug grant somebody like to
move that that apology be sustained
thank you councilman dr secretary
councillor phillips thank you all those
in favor please say aye against the
motion is carried
so councillors is there any declarations
of conflicts with what's on the agenda
this afternoon
there's not thank you
so we'll move on to confirmation
of the minutes
of the last
meeting of council
and would somebody like to move that the
the meeting held in the council chambers
on
the meeting of the council held on the
14th of december uh be seen as a true
and correct record
councillor heisted a signal for that
council mcphail thank you
are there any items that
require correction
there's not i'll put that motion all
those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried
so
urgent late business
uh is there any urgent late business
that needs to be transacted today
does not thank you
and recording in progress
okay
um
so that brings us on to item five and
it's my pleasure to welcome um
ricky from hakanui runanga along to meet
with us today
and to share us share with us uh some of
the values expectations and aspirations
that um the runanga has in the
environmental space
so
ricky
uh you have
somebody with you as well on zoom is
that right
right yeah welcome along courtney
she can hear me
can you hear me courtney
okay
you're on mute courtney sorry
you're right now
uh i can hear you
okay
that's probably a bonus
working on that
ah what's that camera
does that help
uh
technology eh
right oh so uh
welcome ricky and courtney it's great to
have you uh with us today and um
we also have matt uh sitting in from the
plane group thank you
floor is yours
i'm the environmental lead up at the
hokunu irunanga i'm here today with one
of my colleagues
courtney bennett from kitty consulting
so i guess for a start i'll give you a
quick overview of why we why we're here
today
and what we're presenting
this is an accumulation of
the
relationship that was formed uh many
years ago with between the council and
the hoka noirunanga
and it's also the accumulation of
um that treaty partnership that we are
on the journey together with
and over the last couple of years you
may have noticed that we've been a lot
more active in the environmental
area or to tayo
and as part of that
we
with the assistance of kitty consulting
and kawati which is elsa kane who some
of you might be familiar with
have produced a document
for the the war district council
which we'll be presenting here today now
this document
comes from our executive board
it comes from the whanau
as well who have under input and it also
comes from the komahi or the staff up
there as well
so we really wanted to put down in the
document
who we are and why we're so active in
the title space
and why it's important to
as councillors to to interact with ewi
and with ngaitahu and with the
hokunuirung and who we are up there
we had to
edit a lot of it because a lot of it was
a pretty raw form our membership so what
we have done is put it in a nicely
collated way for you to read it's not
very big but it gives a good base
not only for the council but for the
roonanga
so we're all on the same page we all
know the aspirations of the roonaga and
we all know
kind of where we're coming from from in
this space so
i'll quickly go through it i won't go
through it in detail but it'll just be
good i hope everyone's got a copy
we did print out copies for everybody
but unfortunately we had problems with
the printer but that what you have in
front of you the pdf version
it should be all legit it was only when
we printed it on on hard copy
so to cover the tile
is what we're calling it and it is
really about our values our aspirations
and our expectations i really want you
to focus on the expectations part of it
for what we do expect
for our area
and
just an acknowledgement again to kawati
and kitty consulting
i think you're very fortunate to be in a
position as a council to be able to
receive a document that can be used not
only in the tile space
but
in a lot of that resource management
area that user probably also familiar
with
um and it really gives good context uh
to
to building upon and going forward
so at the beginning
this is a whakapapa or a pepe heart just
about
the hokunuirunanga
but at the front
uh after the contents it goes on about
our tohu or our
symbolism for the hakone
[Music]
it's a representative of our landscape
um
[Music]
which is tu te makuhu who was a katie
mamoy chief who lived in hakanui hills
um he lived out of ottawa or
gorge
it was one of the last remaining par out
at the hokanui hills
so that's that uh face that represents a
tupuna there
it's got the mahi which are the arms
overlapping the green tanifa which is
matamata
which we also call
homuri cordon bush
there's a an awesome legend of of
matsumata and the tanifa which most of
you are probably familiar with
if you ever want to know more just let
us know we'll be more than welcome to
come and tell our puraka or our stories
of that area
it goes on to tangoroa which is
the deity of the sea
but also it comes into that freshwater
space which is very important to us
you'll see the two kanakana represented
here which represents our falls and my
total falls
where our
food resource of kanakana still remains
and then the two quarry down the bottom
is for the mataoda which is the klutha
river and the mata adamata oh sorry
which is the clutha and the mataura
which is the matoda
so just down here this this
what this document represents it really
pulls into all the documents that have
been
produced so far around resource
management a big one is te tangia a
tower which is the ewe management plan
which encapsulates all of murihuku and
all the four unaka
and it also uh
represents
the other documents which is the chart
of understanding which we all signed
which majority of you were there for
last year
and then just a few naitahu narratives
around our stance on freshwater and
resource management
hopefully you're all familiar with who
we are
but there's a good there's a great
explanation here of of who the
hakanoirunanga is and how we got
established and who we are as part of
naitahu
and also a little bit of history around
the other papa tipurunanga
i'll tell you i'll let you all read that
in your own time
and then it goes on to a little bit of
that history that i was talking about
with uh
cutting my more chiefs in here as well
so a good bit of history there
for everybody
um
the values
in here they are
uh quite generic values and they they
are from
generic and naitahu but we've also made
them uh quite specific to the hokunu
irunanga as well
so
these
values are
what we go off in all of our everyday
aspirations but but also in our
documentation and the resource
management
every time we go into a consent or to a
hearing or
anything to do with resource management
these values is what we draw upon
so if any of you want to get familiar
in that world that this is what we pull
upon
and it has excellent um
meanings in here as well so i think
it'll be very helpful for for any any
documentation going forward
we always get a lot of questions around
mahinga kai and whatnot so a very very
useful resource
we go into our interests of the area um
kiwitaki tai which means from the
mountain to the sea
that we go into our
way or our water
beautiful picture there of the total
falls
and then we also go into a bit more
detail around mahingakai uh
which comes up a lot as well
um
and the likes so
a great resource for council
to pull up on and also for us as hokunui
because this is what we do use as a
foundation document
uh heading to the back i'm going to pass
this over to courtney bennett because
part of her
research was
that this back end and it's something
that not only will have adapted but a
lot of the maitahu
papatipulunga have adapted as well
and it really goes into the
collaboration between ewe and crown and
local government and and and ue as well
so i'll let you take over and talk to us
courtney
thank
you yeah that's
what ricky said is exactly right so the
idea behind putting this document
together
was to create a reference place for both
um ourselves as
kai mahiro employees of the learning are
working on environmental space
but also for the wider community and our
treaty partners here at the council
so that we
all know
what we're talking about we will have a
shared understanding of what specific
values mean in a new context
what our priorities areas are
all those kind of things
yeah just so that we all have that very
shared understanding
the section at the back
uh expectations
involvement in environmental management
and there's been a lot of research
that's gone on different areas by
different people that have talked about
the way that
um engagement between
crown and council and
is a bit of a minefield
you've got
usually you've got parties that both
want to do the right thing they both
have the same goals but they're just not
quite sure how to
how to communicate those things to each
other so we thought it would be useful
to include some best practice
engagement strategies in this document
and after popping them in here
has
endorsed this to be the way that they
would like to be engaged with going
forward
so if we go to page 16
there's a clear
a clear
a clear diagram here that talks about
what are the physical
practical on the ground things that
people can do to ensure that they're
engaging in a best practice way so
that's around proactive research early
and ongoing engagement resourcing
monophenolis experts and loot protocol
and it's got a quick rundown of what
each of those mean in practice
so we just really encourage
anyone who's engaging with
to have a quick look through this first
and see how they can
embody these key focused areas and
things of best practice engagement when
deciding how they want to come and speak
to the donor
so i'll throw it back to you
i killed it
courtney so
that's basically it um in a nutshell so
i'm more than happy to to answer any
questions and
i hope these i hope there is a few but
this is really a reflection of um of
where we're at so far in terms of our
relationship together
um we've had our ups and downs as we'll
probably do in relationships
but um you know this is this is just us
um working with the council uh to
hopefully uh make things more efficient
and in processes but also in terms of
that engagement and partnership as well
so kilda coaching
yokura um ricky and i just want to say
thank you for the proactive stance
you've taken here by putting this before
us as we begin on our journey
around engagement and understanding and
working together in a much stronger way
than possibly we have in the past i
think it's very clear and concise
and some i think we can all learn a lot
from that i also
i'm very appreciative of the
the offer you make to be available uh
for any questions that
i or councillors or staff might have
about just the processes
because i think we
sometimes we
we sort of
stand back and don't ask but we won't
learn if we don't ask so
so thank you for that um
i'm just going to open it up for any
counsellors who may want to make any
comment or or ask
any questions of either ricky or
courtney
but i think it's it's pretty clear and
is it going to be a very useful tool for
us
going forward from here
so councillors floors yours if you have
any comments you wish to make council
dixon
sorry council dixon can you just put
your microphone on please
speak up
thank you worship um it's a very
clear document and and well set out and
i imagine that this will feed into our
district plan
um ricky
it'll be it'll be very useful absolutely
and this
was not the sole purpose but but a good
contributing factor was this district
planning process
and how could we
not only ourselves um
have a good platform to refer back to
and move forward but also to show the
council
where we're getting that information
from and how we're and how we're
building from it so it's really a
sharing document there
i'll pass it up to anybody on the zoom
if they want to
speak to
the contribution of this document to the
district plan
um yeah i'll take them
so a lot of the text from the draft of
this document
has already faded into sections of the
district plan
and those of you that are on the
district and subcommittee
when you're reading through the values
and expectations none of those will
sound new to you because it's all the
things that we've been saying
and discussing but we've just decided to
pop it all in one place so that we can
make sure that
we're being
consistent because we're all literally
reading off the same sheet
goodbye
great
counselors any thoughts comments
no everybody's clear
thank you okay look thank you ricky and
say thank you courtney uh for your
contribution today and
we um we look forward to um
continuing the journey
thank you
okay we'll move on then to item six
which is
urban environment assessment and we have
a
a report from a planning consultant and
matt's here to um to speak to that i
think matt said
do you want to speak to that now
know me my name is um hill
i'm a principal chair of the property
group
and i'm leading the district plan review
i'll just give you a quick rundown of
paper
basically the paper outlines that gore
district
qualifies as an urban environment under
the
new national policy statement urban
developments
because you have a combined housing
labor
of at least 10 000 people
um
this has been confirmed through
discussions with the ministry of
environment
the paper outlines the implications for
particularly
there's a requirement to remove
minimum parking standards
monitor housing business supply and
demand
and potentially become eligible for
additional central government funding
as well as
elevating the importance of the [ __ ] area
both regionally and nationally
the paper goes through this in detail so
i'm not going to run through that
the paper recommends that
council confirm
or as an urban environment um
remove some unpacking standards and
um
undertakes the required monitoring work
uh to support the classification needs
and different environment
so
um three of me as i said happy to answer
questions
if you've got any questions on the
detail of the paper
thank you matt um
okay councillors the um the floor is
open for any questions or comments
counselor hosted
yeah three-year worship i've just i got
a question regarding um
the inclusion of matera but the
exclusion of mandeville waikeka and
pokhara
what's the logic around that and also
in that explanation any implications of
bringing matera in
through the mirror
basically
the reason
has material included is because it's
more urban in nature
than uh smaller settlements
um
in terms of implications
uh they are kind of set out in the paper
they largely focus on law but the same
applies to matera
so
removing the minimum parking standards
so
if a developer is providing parking they
still need to design that parking to
council standards um so you know the
minimum dimensions for parking spaces
and those sorts of things
so it's just removing the requirement
for them to provide
the minimum parking standards in the
district plan so for example
if it's a residential development it's
um
one site a one park per dwelling or
two parks where that dwelling's over 100
square meters
so the other implications that you
outline in your report regarding council
monitoring and having to take into
account they apply regardless of whether
we
we
approve a classification as an urban
environment or does that occur when that
happens
so the monitoring of things like housing
supply and demand are a requirement once
you're classified as an urban
environment
um
the property group has been doing that
work anyway to support the development
of the district plan sorry
it would just be a continuation
of that work
in terms of monitoring i also talked
about
the good idea to keep monitoring the
demand for parking as we move forward
so if there are
any actions council needs to take in
terms of
providing on-street marketing then
we can factor that in in the future
just one last thing for me the
recommendation this the second paragraph
asks us to prove that gore be classified
should that be gore and matera or was
that recommendation correct the way i
read it
yeah i guess it should be
good spotting
okay um
any other questions or comments from
councillors
quite a big shift in what
we've been doing for a number of years
around
parking requirements so
personally a step in the right direction
in my view
um if there's no further comments i'll
um
ask from mover
uh no i've got a question
sometimes it's difficult for businesses
to find space to provide parking and so
there's been a
financial contribution but it still
doesn't solve the issue that that
some people would say there's never
enough parking
so
what do we do about that you know do we
do we have a a dedicated area where we
council's responsible to provide parking
and if council's responsible to provide
parking that means the right power pays
so
i i can see us heading heading down that
that direction
we want we want businesses we don't want
to
make it uh difficult for businesses to
establish
the course if business is established
and they haven't got any way of getting
people to that business uh there's a
little bit of a problem
that's right i've got no solutions it's
an easy question to ask i'm just
interested in what other people might
have to
say as they consider that yeah no look
um you raised some good points
but i don't have an answer um
i'm not sure whether any other
counselors have an answer or the chief
executive has an answer to that
particular um quandary i guess there is
going to be a responsibility for for
council to make sure that
the requirements of our community are
being met and parking just fits into
that as well so
and and obviously there are there will
be some cost and
as with everything that council does it
comes down to the rate payer meeting
that that bill
there's a couple of observations i could
make one is that these provisions
have in the past proved to be quite a
problem
in
trying to facilitate new development
where you've got to provide a minimum
amount of parks and sometimes it has
been there i sat
incredibly lateral and creative
interpretations to try and get something
over the line where parks
some distance from the establishment
have been designated as being that that
will suffice to service that
establishment which brings brings me i
guess to the next point which is that
um there may need to be just a little
bit of recalibration in people's minds
particularly in say gore
about that you might have to walk 100
meters or so before you get to the your
venue of choice
seems to me that a lot of people have a
a very deep seated expectation that
they'll be able to drive their car and
be within a handful of steps of their
chosen business premises
but you wouldn't actually have that
expectation if you visited a larger
centre say further north of the allied
dunedin so
that's that's one way because when you
look around the cbd and the outlying
periphery there is actually an abundance
of parks it just means you have to walk
a little bit further than perhaps you
you would normally
desire
um
the
last recommendation talks about uh
directing council officers to communist
monitoring parking demand
and so that's a way of
working out on an ongoing basis without
there is enough on street parking and
where the council needs to intervene in
there so there's an opportunity to
through this recommendation to
ensure there's enough on street parking
to address any issues
okay
right council dixon
three worship i was just wondering is
there any funding available to carry out
the survey or is it just another cost
to our rate payers from central
government
i suspect the latter
okay so um
if there's no further questions we have
once more small edition that's adding uh
matera after gore in first
recommendation or second recommendation
some would like to move that be
the recommendations be confirmed
counselor make sure now do i have a
second day for that counselor reid thank
you
is there any discussion does not i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carrot no from
council bulger
just because you could
um
all right we'll move on then to item
seven
which is uh symmetry by law and we have
a memo from parks and recreation manager
keith
keith do you want to introduce this to
us before we open for discussion yeah i
will um
i
just see um
the bylaw and the
cemetery's handbook
most of it is around
change of wording and change of style um
the original bylaw
goes back to 2008 and it was amended in
2017 um
wording the layout and the original
document i would say was probably quite
old-fashioned um
so i
did a bit of an investigation looking at
um
a number of councils including central
otago district council um in the cargo
city
queenstown lakes waitaki district and
klutha district
so
i guess the resulting document for the
bylaw i i believe flows better
there's a bit of stuff in there about um
i just around wording the the original
by-law talked about a cemetery manager
um cordless council had never had such a
position so i i might have been trying
to elevate the
role of sex and but i i think we're
probably um
trying to be more consistent now so you
know we talk about a sex and a sexton's
assistant in a cemetery administration
officer so that i think that's
probably all terms that people are quite
comfortable with um
the the other thing the
original bylaw talked about uh cremation
and um again we uh councils never had a
crematorium so
i don't think i'm remiss in removing
that from the document really so it
doesn't have any impact on
the way we run around the cemeteries
in terms of the cemeteries handbook uh
well sorry um
the old document was uh it was called an
operations
uh policies and procedures and and i
think that's probably um
a number of councils have gone gone to
the handbook
wording and and that's
essentially
the handbook is really the day-to-day
document that the
council staff would be referring to um
the um
i guess there's probably three or four
changes that are probably
significant in there
one is around the hours of operation
the current document talks about six
days
six days a week operation nine to four
um
the new document i have just made a
change with um
talked about summer hours and winter
hours and and
summer was nine to four so unchanged and
then the winter hours i've said nine to
three thirty and and i guess that's
primarily around um
health and safety um you know i kind of
was a bit dismayed when sexton's
actually still working at seven o'clock
in the dark in the middle of winter and
and i think it's probably um
that that change is consistent with it
with the number of other southern
councils so you know i don't think it's
unreasonable um
i did also make a change at saturday
nine to one um but i i i actually
realise that's an error
that was based around um cost recovery i
didn't believe we were recovering costs
so i
saturday should actually remain nine to
four so um
yeah the other thing in there is um
there's additional clauses uh one is
around special procedures for maori
burials
we didn't have that covered at all in
the
previous document and the other one we
it was around religious denominational
burials um again we didn't have it
covered previously and
one in particular is um
we have a muslim
burial beam at pokhara cemetery and and
that is now um accommodated in their
documents
so yeah that that's uh that's all the
comments i need to make thank you keith
um so effectively bringing us into the
2020s in terms of terminology and um and
style um
steve do you want to make any comment
before i open the full discussion
okay i think it's fairly straightforward
but uh open full discussion by councils
now so councillor hosted
you thank you worship um
just through you and maybe i tried to
read it all but the plot next door was
generally available for purchase my
understanding in the previous policy so
your your family could buy
the adjoining plot
i couldn't find that in this policy is
that something that
i've missed it's
moved on uh did that not exist
i'm just not sure that is right um
keith do you want to make a comment
yeah um certainly not the intent you
know that that's a recognized procedure
for most councils in new zealand so yeah
we could just check that the other
question i had is under 3.5 and it's
probably out of our existing policy it
says that the council this is on page 35
that we wouldn't buy an unused plot that
would seem that symmetries are
exceedingly extremely short in supply
especially some of the older
cemeteries so if a plot did come
back to council i couldn't see any harm
in that
why would we exclude ourselves from
repurchasing a previously sold plot it
doesn't make sense to me
i'm interested i i believe that's um
something that goes as part of the
cemeteries and burials act and um
you know i think the council previously
had it was something around after 60
years um
the ownership of the plot becomes um
available so yeah i i just
probably just need to check that
actually it's actually the one below
that yeah
yeah it's just simply if someone buys a
plot
and they wish to sell it they can
transfer it to someone else but not the
council
hmm
okay so this is going out for
consultation now isn't it so
yeah i'm sure we'll get some comments
um
around those
yeah
what if we don't you russia what's the
what's the procedure if we if we don't
get feedback
can counsellors make changes now
subject to guidance from the staff
before those changes are made before it
goes out
do you want to make a
comment are you asking can you make
changes now um absolutely this is this
is a proposal for consultation if you
think there are some
amendments required this is your chance
to suggest those amendments
and
uh if
if and i probably would if the
amendments are substantial or need some
word smithing i would suggest that we
bring it back a revised refined draft
for approval to publicly notify the next
meeting if it's straightforward we can
do it
on the fly tonight
so i guess what you're suggesting brett
is that the bottom line
be
deleted from that by-law
no i'm suggesting that it's in the
handbook i think
that there's absolute clarity given that
that family can buy a plot next door to
um
in the event of a
i guess what i'm looking at is 3.5 and
3.5 yeah that that final sentence but
that's certainly to the moon to the rest
of the council
that would be my intent yeah no just
before we open it up for further
discussion
look i think um councillor heist has
raised a good point here
uh and i'm keen to hear from other
councillors
on this issue councillor bulger um
just another
question or seeking some clear clarity
clause 3.6 pre-purchase
council does not pre-sale any of the
exclusive bureau rights
the exclusive bureau rights can only be
purchased at the time of internment okay
that's fine so how does how does someone
reserve the adjacent plot
uh how's that managed
really okay same thing
so
steve do you want to make your worship
yeah i think um
i'd like to uh
think about this a bit further because
uh
if if you go down that track you can
have
a lot of empty holes in your cemetery
for
sometimes decades
and
then you've got
burials being affected between two
existing graves and that presents an
increased element of danger so i just
think before we say yes or no i'd like
to just get some
have some time to think about that and
perhaps also defer to
what some of our neighbours allow or
don't allow so it's
there's always that urge if i want to
have a
plot but increasingly there's
use of one plot and and two people
within it so you know a husband and wife
for example can be buried together um
but whether
whether the intention is to allow
um or what what the pros and cons are of
symmetry management of allowing a family
to preserve an adjacent plot that may
not be used for say for
many years
that's the type of thing i think we need
to get some advice on and so that we are
quite
excused upon sure of our ground as to
how we approach this matter
good
i recall we worked through this and
that's where we got to one plot but i
stand to be corrected and i guess it's
another point to make it would be very
useful to have a marked up copy of a
previous policy so that we can see what
in fact we are changing
um rather than trying to take it as a
new policy yeah
okay uh john i think the work ones only
allow you to have
not not to pre-purchase
they don't
i think it's the reason steve gave
okay um keith did you want to make any
further comment at all at this point
i believe the wording actually does
allow for a family member to um
at the time of
internment to purchase the plot next
door so i i believe that word and covers
that so
so so you they they at the time of
internment they either by um purchase a
double depth
which accommodates the partner or
the family member or they have the
option of
the plot next storm so
yeah so i believe that's covered yeah
yeah
okay
so are we comfortable with that
yeah council got on
just the timing or need change to the
booklet for saturday and there will be
change before it goes out yeah
okay um look thank you for those points
and it's um it's good to get them
clarified uh before we go
any further down this this particular
track
but we do um
do have a recommendation
and
if there's no further questions or
comments from councillors i'll ask if
someone would
approve or
move
the two recommendations relating to this
issue
councillor dixon thank you
double signer for that
councilman thank you
uh any further questions or comments
there's not i'll put the motion all
those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried so this
will now proceed to consultation and
will come back before us uh again in due
course
right so that brings us to item eight um
and again more public consultation uh on
the draft goal district council
stormwater management uh bylaw
that we need to put in place for the
process that we've
commenced
last month and due to
close on the 25th of february this month
so we need to have some counsellors to
sit on a hearing panel
for that
and do you want to perhaps give us a
little bit of a insight on what that
involves
mr chief executive from timewise
i think there's one there's one meeting
is it what's up is it one meeting or two
meetings yes uh well i assume it will be
one meeting uh unless there are issues
raised by submitters that require
further research or consideration
um as to how many
submissions we get
and how complex they may be in terms of
issues
raised
that's
really
indeterminate at this point in time
but i would be surprised if we were
against us with deluge with lots of
submissions
okay so we need to appoint some
counsellors is anybody
breaking the neck to be on this
particular uh panel
um council macphail looks at eager at
that point um
council may fail um
councillor grant nick grant
and perhaps one more council dixon how
would you feel about being on that one
okay
does anybody else really want to be on
that
if not
with a recommendation we'll read council
macphail councillor nick grant and
council dixon be appointed to the
hearing panel thank you very much for
your voluntary effort
and
would somebody like to move that
recommendation
counselor davis thank you i've seen the
council guard on all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried thank you very much you worship
guys ask the supplementary question on
that yes that item just in terms of the
question to matt i guess for you is a
question regarding the um
the user group or the catchment group um
how's that progressing and where does
that fit in
during
the lead up to the
closing of the submissions
through your worship um
my
vision was that the user group would i
guess
implement the bilo or look at ways of
implementing the bottom of the bottles i
guess reasonably high level
and and i guess sets the standards that
we want to make and it would be the user
group that i guess
works through the practicalities of
exactly how they met um
so it would be after the bylaw is put in
place it's sort of my
so i guess i guess the question would be
um if there's going to be a user group
should they be coordinated free the
bylaw and
make use of the information and the
knowledge that they have is that what
you're suggesting outside i see
yeah
you have any thoughts around that one
matt
um
yeah i guess potentially it could be
um
it will obviously delay the
implementation of the bylaw um
but
it is not an issue with that
um
how many users are we talking about
yeah i guess it
depends how much interest there is but i
had envisaged it being
around that
four to six to keep it rather you know
reasonably streamlined
i've had
one
formal
expression of interest in another two
that
um certainly
they haven't expressed an interest to be
on the working group but they're
certainly um i think
so is
is that sort of group and that sort of
process something that counselor council
could be involved in
to implement
yeah so yeah
so
given that you raised the point
against the high said would you be
interested in
making contact with those
users um on
and see where we can get to in terms of
a view on the
pros bylaw
you're sure i'm happy to be part of
something but i guess i see it as a
staff's role to
get the group together and and i think a
couple of councillors
should be involved
um
quite difficult to lead that
from a political point of view without
staff support so
i guess happy to be
put my hand up and say
but i think we should personally i think
let the submission process carry forward
but get on with it and show meaningful
engagement with that group and so
they're up and running ready to ready to
swing into action because it's probably
our time now and see with the close date
okay good point so um councillor jose
has put his hand up and said he's
prepared to be part of such a group is
there any other councils would like to
be part of that discussion
can i be on the panel
probably
not
yeah they can be on the panel because
the panel only have powers of
recommendations
if you wish um
there's no conflicts of interest
okay so you indicating an interest
counselor phillips
okay
you're comfortable with that both of you
right
council's comfortable with that
could we just put a time frame on it to
assist the staff is to to win with the
council
councillors would like there to be
something i think it would have to be
sooner rather as soon as possible we've
got a fairly short time till the end of
the submissions haven't we is it doable
i guess
for the team
through your worship
well from my point of view i see the
the working group or the um the
the process that we need to go through
and that could could be quite a long
period um but there's nothing stopping
us getting that working group formed and
having the first meeting and and some
initial discussions before the bylaw
hearing submissions close
so you think that's that's possible and
practical
okay yeah i think so yeah
all right let's work down that track
thank you
um thank you council high sip for
raising that um item nine
um
and we have a memo from the admin
manager with regard to issuing of uh
staff warrants and authorisations
for
uh various positions
um
who's going to speak to this
you think
it's just uh with any uh new
change of staffing in the regulatory
area we need to have them fully
warranted just in case their issues
emerge and they need to have the
authority to act under the local
government and that authority is vested
in the elected members of the council
okay uh open for discussion any
questions counselors might have with the
process
thank you i was second for that
council davis thank you
um no further discussion i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
um so it brings us on to item 10
fluoridation of drinking water supplies
and we have a
memo here for a report here from um
three waters asset manager
which is
laying out the the challenge we have
due
in part or whole um
relating to the letter that's come from
the um director general of health ashley
bloomfield so matt do you want to speak
to this
through your worship i i don't think i
have too much to add to the report um i
guess it's it's something that's
obviously been talked about for some
time now
um but
if if you haven't already i'd
certainly encourage you to have a look
at the information that's
on the ministry of health website around
fluoridation because i certainly found
that um quite informative
happy to take any questions thank you
matt and this is not something that
hasn't been before this council before
it's been before this council on a
number of times um however it does seem
to be um taking a much more directed
view now councillor bulger
while i'm aware of the benefits of
fluoridation
i'm not comfortable
with uh
mandate from on high and so i assume
and i know that you're keen to always
have submissions from the public that we
go through some process
and i know
that there'll be opposing views and they
will be
substantial as i i see this really quite
a difficult
direction to take
uh but it does seem clear that director
general is pointing us and giving us a
direction that way
i'm not comfortable with it i can
understand the reason for it okay i'd
like to hear other people's comments
thank you council boss
bulger and and as i said this has been
before this council over the last
20 or 30 years a number of times and
from my understanding gore at once one
point was fluoridated but then chose to
to not be fluoridated i guess from a
from i understand what you're saying uh
absolutely and and none of us like to be
told what to do there's no doubt about
that
and we're seeing that on a daily basis
almost on an hourly basis with regarding
to um to covert
but what i am really concerned about and
i
i guess my um
my leaning on this is is on a pro stance
um as i hear and i see the damage that's
going on particularly in our young
people but not just our young people's
oral care the whole community
you know we
we pride ourselves on the fact that we
have access to the mobile surgical unit
coming to gore and doing some really
good stuff
over 80 percent
of the time that they spend in gore is
all to do with bad oral health and
fixing up the the problems that
have been created
particularly with children but not just
with children
so
i hear exactly what you're saying
and i guess i'll refer to the chief
executive just in terms of
what direction
what direction we should go in in terms
of if if the suggestion council bulges
is saying is that we we ask for
submissions what that might look like
and what status would that have
be careful yes
i i note the recommendation uh the
director and teacher to start
considering
issuing directions so it's it's a slow
it's a slow process
uh
of maybe information
uh
rather than
jumping knee deep into consultation
would that be more
useful approach i guess it depends on
what your outcome is
but what is desirable
from my perspective
having
particularly children's oral health
improve dramatically
is the outcome that we should be
considering
and looking at as a council
certainly we can make this go slow
but
at the end of the day i believe it'll be
the community that suffer
if we do that
because um mr chief executive do you
want to make any comment
i think uh you think your worship
i think the notion of consultation
uh this won't be one of those
you see in dr bloomfield's letter he
talks about direction
and this is as a direct result of the
local government sector collectively
saying
we don't want this hot potato
south taranaki district council and at
the time we thought the grace of god go
i or us
were involved in a brutal judicial
review over fluoridation
so south taranaki won district council
one was introduced fluoridation and the
anti-fluoridation
brigade took that council to court under
a judicial review application i
understand it took a couple years but
there's certainly there was six figure
some spent on defending its actions and
that spawned
a plea that
can maybe some type of central strategy
to avoid individual councils being
dragged into court
and
you always knew that there was going to
be a segment of the population didn't
want it and a segment of the population
that did want it and the
local government view collectively that
this was a health issue that needed to
be actually owned
and directed by the ministry of health
and that's now what we've got through
this legislation
okay um so
another question one more statement
really
surely central government if they want
fluid
as part of their three waters directive
they should include it
rather than passing this hot potato
to us
and i understand that there's a concern
about
oral health and young people and the
ongoing costs and problems that'll
they'll
produce so i can see the merit in it
okay um open for discussion
um just for matt really what is the kind
of conditions of our piping through gore
have we got many metal pipes running
through our water systems i know houses
are mainly made up of copper pipes
copper cylinders from a plumbing point
of view the fluoridation is going to
make me lots of money because it's going
to eat copper expose
lead-based properties intactware and
that therefore affecting people's health
so we've really got to look at that too
because if we start getting more sick
people because of the duration of the
tap wear and their pipework um that's
going to make us and put us in the
firing line
for those direct results
so
from from our from our point of view
what are our
treatment plants like and what are our
water pipes like underneath is he
anything going through gal or steel
through your worship
um we
there's
we have some
gulf uh water connections um
predominantly
the
reticulated mains are
a cast iron
asbestos or pvc or pe so
i'm yeah i'm not aware of any studies
around the impact of
fluoridation on council infrastructure
and what effect that might
have but would certainly be interesting
um to know
especially after we spent so much money
yeah certainly the upgraded treatment
plants um
i wouldn't have too many concerns um
around the impact on them yeah but still
a lot of properties in goal with
galvanized water mains especially a lot
of the older houses
um and uh in rest haven i know that's
got a big four inch galvanized steel
main gun in there
and a lot of that place is actually
copper a lot of it is copper
so they could be good at looking at good
maintenance pills over there over the
years
mother
well pretty much just a statement
we're all worried about children's oral
health
it's a big thing but who's to say that
those children are actually going to
drink that water and they haven't been
haven't got poor diets and not drinking
and drinking fizzies anyway
so are we actually going to change
anything
i guess
i take the points you're making nick
neck
and look i wasn't aware of the
the impact that fluoride might have on
on the piping system i certainly news to
me
and i just don't know how big an issue
that that would likely to be i do know
that if you compare the communities up
and down the country that are
fluoridated and the ones that aren't the
condition of the oral health is is stark
uh from the ones that did not
and
i know that this brings out
the pros and the cons
in terms of community and
we've been fluoridated in the past and
then thrown it out
we've been asked a few times we've had
tim mckay
sort of a professor from otago come and
speak to council some pretty compelling
arguments but councils decided not to
because of
the fear that we're telling people what
to do
personally as i've said before i think
the health of the community comes first
and
we should be doing all we can to
ensure that that rises rather than than
falls this is just an opportunity for
that but um
i guess this is only just a step in the
the direction
any other counselor read
thank you your worship
i know there are i don't think we can
dispute the benefits to young people but
also um i i do know that
as we get older um if you've got poor
oral health it actually leads to a lot
of other ongoing issues with the body as
well
and we also have lots of additives to
other things that we eat like our bread
for instance in our salt
so
from that point of view
i just think
okay if the director of health is
pushing us in this direction
um
obviously that our hands are tied anyway
to a certain point and i do understand
also that at some point when the water
enters your house
there is an opportunity to take the
fluoride out
stand to be corrected on that but i
think it can be
here here so for those that perhaps felt
quite strongly about it and they don't
want to drink it that may be an
opportunity for them to do something
else but um
i just think we need to be open-minded
about it and i do know that many people
in the community are anti but
you know general health benefits so
i'm in favor of it
okay any other
questions or comments around the table
council macphail then council davis
yes thank you worship just um really a
commentary for myself in relation to the
benefits
um if we do have such a poor oral health
uh
record in the area we'll probably pay to
show that to actually show what our
stats are and actually give some
indication of the community of how poor
we are
because clearly in
dr bloomfield's
direction or as in his implementation
of his plan
he's indicating that it's large
population areas with extremely
poor oral health so i think for the
benefit of the community we need to have
that stated because we aren't a large
population but clearly if we have got
low oral health well that's probably the
selling point for him
the second thing is obviously the
filters that people have brought up and
the third thing is is you're going to
fluoride
do
fluoridation of all the bottled water in
new zealand as well because i believe
there's actually substantial sales and
product on the market that generally a
lot of people drink that other than
taking as a councillor grant said tap
water um
be an interesting question to throw out
there
thank you
yeah
council red just another point your
worship and
backing up um councillor mcphail's
comment it'll be interesting to see how
gore
children and the tower children and
waikaka etc actually stack up in those
numbers
if that's at all possible
thank you
okay so um oh sorry council dave's
yeah thank you worship i'm just
wondering where we're at as far as
the capital works funding goes
i see there's a small amount available
through the government
but that's for councils that get in
early so
how well is more information to come or
do we have that information yet
because it's quite a substantial amount
for matera plant alone and if you add
the gall plant on that's half a million
dollars
more or less
through your worship i i think yeah
there'll be more information to come on
that um
while
dr bloomfield's considering issuing
directions from
mid-2022 onwards i don't think the time
frame will be
super short in terms of getting everyone
compliant with it so i suspect there'll
be a fair bit of time there to
look at funding
um so it'll be council's intention to
apply for that funding
i would assume so yeah absolutely
and
based on through your worship based on
past experiences with funding funding
schemes of this type
i'd be very surprised if there wasn't a
prioritization given to deprivation
index so communities at a
lower associate economic
profile would probably get more priority
for funding in which case the likes of
the tara given that we've got a
reasonably sized um
a gap to fund there would likely score
well if that's the the approach the
government takes and that certainly can
approach a variety of schemes over the
past probably 10 years both in
wastewater and other areas
okay um
council guideline
yeah obviously if we borrow the money it
would be
paid over to three waters the loan would
be passed over and hasn't been checked
out or was it presumed that the council
would wear that
uh if any any borrowing certainly would
ultimately find its way to and transfer
to the new three waters entity yes
councilor phillips
thank you
while i agree with
the transfer of the funds the store two
year gap roughly a two year gap before
that would happen so therefore the
poorer ratepayer once again has to try
and fork out another quarter of a
million to a half a million dollars
extra for a mandate that some people
don't even require now to me
that's i think we just all moved to
china the way things are going at the
moment
well that's a sweeping statement council
phillips
realize your desire to go to china it
was so great um okay um
we'll open it up for any further
discussion
uh
about council dixon
thank you worship
what i'm wondering is where is
parents responsibility in this because i
know that
a lot of people don't get their children
to clean their teeth they keep giving
them fizzy drinks
if the
if mr bloomfield is so concerned about
the health of the teeth why is it does
he not do something
about
people buying huge amounts of
sugary drinks and feeding it to their
children
yeah look i understand completely the
point you're making
i'm not sure what could be done in that
respect
i just simply don't know
you know i just wonder about the timing
with covert and all the regulations
we've got and then we're just going to
pop this one in and i think it's
probably going to like a bomb shelf
that's what i'm a bit afraid of but i'm
not against it but i think the timings
are wrong
so i guess there's been um
i'm not sure who mentioned it but um
somebody wanting to see some more data
around what we look like as a community
i think that would be a good next step
that councilman fail i think it was i
think that would be good good next step
and and i'm pretty sure that data will
be reasonably freely available both
locally and and centrally so
counselor phillips think your worship so
then do we ask matt then as the three
waters manager for the gdc that he
continues on with the aspect of having
us mandated to have fluoridation in our
two water plants because
it would be silly for us not to have
becker doing what the
plans in matera currently at the moment
um and having the building set
up for it
if it does if it is mandated that means
then we have to go back and spend
another
sum of money
to to do it do we just
at the currently say okay let's spend
the extra five thousand at the moment
say just say for a figure that we spend
the money and say to beckett right
put it in the plans for future use
or
do we take the gamble and say no
okay i guess that's why you're a
counsellor
counselor phillips
do you want to make a comment yeah you
worship i think at this stage
given the overall
general sense of
unease in the community about
how
the community's responding to covert
you've got a statement of intent and
that's all you've got from the
government the legislation's passed we
don't we don't have a
surefire
knowledge of timing i would urge just a
little bit of
conservative a conservative approach
no
it may come
the
government is moving
but whether it will have a demand on
a whole host of communities by stripping
within strict deadlines
i personally doubt it but
if it does we deal with it at this stage
the
information is for you to note
and to be aware that
this may come but you'd be better off i
would have thought
of responding to a government directive
rather than jumping in and saying we
think it might happen are we going to
stimulate the debate and do the job now
where
as council uh some councils have said
the timing isn't perhaps flash
so my strong advice is to adopt a
watching brief
and
this legislation was passed to take the
pressure and the heat
from local government use that and let
the directive
fall at your lap when it will and then
we'll deal with it
i totally agree with some
your comments around timing i think it
would
be good for this council to have access
to the data that we
can access locally though so just so we
know what the current situation is
councilor bulger
comfortable with the chief executive and
your own point of view
that we wait for a firm directive and
because the recommendation
uh states that the information received
i'll move the recommendation
okay
uh so you're moving just received
yeah okay so do you want to see further
data
yeah okay
so the report be received and that we
source uh relevant data to this area
from the health department and from
local sources
all those in favor please say uh oh do
we have a segment
so actually council make to now a second
thing
yeah sorry i just um
at that
discussion my intention is and i'm happy
to change it if the council desires but
my intention is to ask becker to design
the treatment plan upgrade at matera
to incorporate
fluoridation in the future
so that if we do get that direction we
can easily upgrade
um yeah but
look it makes sense to do that i think
okay um
good discussion and um
it's interesting to note that over the
years the the arguments haven't really
changed or the attitudes haven't changed
both for and against
um right i'll put that motion all those
in favor please say aye against the
motion is carried thank you
um
we have minutes of the matera community
board
um
to be received and recommendations uh
ratified
somebody like to move those
i moved council grant
to a second of that
council phillips thank you
any discussion or question
council read
thank you your worship um just a comment
about the bridge with the kids jumping
off the bridge and i say you've been
involved in that counselor phillips
is it worth going through the schools
and having the schools visit the site
and maybe talk some of the younger kids
through that
the danger of it
so
there's actually been quite a lot of
effort gone in over the last six to
eight weeks um since i'm sure when that
meeting was
um and
look i think
personally i think this the um
the children know the dangers
uh absolutely it
does seem to be
a challenge there though
for them like councillor phillips
do you want to make any comment
i think you wish no there's nothing much
i can add to what you've already seen
there has been a lot of work going on in
the background
from the principal of the school
as well as well as our
community connector
and
there was a lot of discussion held on
that night of the meeting
um i think it's been a passage of right
for children
ever since we can remember basically
the only concern that we have is
crossing over the arches and then
crossing over the center arch to the
next arch on the other side to jump over
the other way
and the
mess it could make
on the road as they fall off
but
that's the main concern
really
we've talked about signage and the
roading manager was
asked to instigate that so
that's about all we can do okay
um yeah so councillors may or may not be
aware that a community connector which
is a government-funded position has been
appointed in to matera and doing some
really good stuff i'd have to say
she's been very proactive
in engaging the whole community in this
particular challenge
and particularly the the mirai have been
very active there so
council reads wright and councillor
phillips is right
this has been going on for decades
it's unlikely to stop now
and
but we do need to make sure that people
are aware of the dangers they're putting
themselves in
sorry
another question about that report and
um i just note too that uh the community
connector
saying that basketball was very popular
and i know it is even in gore here
um and i was just wondering is there any
opportunity for parks and reserves maybe
to look at installing the hoops extra
hoops at
queen's park and even in gore a lot of
the young ones out at the mirai or out
at the renault um they play out there
but there's really nowhere in town for
them with proper basketball hoops
do you want me to comment that one
neville just with regard to them tara
community
uh
i think i just passed this one to keith
because we have um had several
discussions in with the material what's
required what's happening and
and you can
let you know
um yeah just following on um the the
in the tower of the um we we have uh
reinstated a backboard at
tullock park
and
it was marked out last week for half
court basketball which is
essentially the game that everybody
wants to play and
yeah we
uh
we've had a similar request from escort
and uh
i think we in our budget we as part of a
swan street playground development we
had um
we had another unit going in there so um
yeah so i think yeah we are trying to
cover that base off really and and it um
yeah i i guess it um
meets a group of
teenage
kids that you know uh otherwise would be
um
possibly involved in the other business
yeah and desirable
yeah
thank you very much for being so
proactive
thank you okay
is uh council phillips thank you yeah i
can only just say to um the keith's
proactiveness has
is uh been noted in the last few months
in materan and um
it's a huge thank you to not only him
but to gail as well and
yeah the the children of matera really
enjoyed the summer um even though they
were jumping off the material bridge
which a bit of a disappointment
and next priority of course is matera is
to get um air
water park
constructed in their second stage italic
park and a few other things that
are coming up
okay so we have a
a report that's moved and seconded
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried
so it brings us on to item 12 which is
the emergency committee that was
established prior to the christmas
holiday period
the committee didn't need to meet at any
point so
the recommendation is that
the information be received and council
emergency committee be disbanded
somebody like to move that
recommendation counselor reed of
secondary counselor bulger thank you
uh all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors that brings us to the end of
the
open
session of
the council meeting
and